[موسيقى]
السياسيه قويه جدا في السياقه التركيه
والجماعات الدينيه في الحقيقه
على الارجح موده خمسينات القرن الماضي
ولكنهم
عندك كسبوا هذا النفوذ الكبير
حكم الحزب العداله والتنميه
عام 2002
الى الجماعات الدينيه المختلفه والسعاده
ضمن المجتمع الا تركي وكذلك ضمن القضائي
والجيش التركي تركيا
اتونا من هذه الجماعات الدينيه ويقدمون
تبرعات كثيره
[موسيقى]
استفادت من هذه الجماعات الدينيه ولكن
باتجالين بانحب العداله والتنميه هو
المستفيده الرئيسي لانه هو الحزب الذي
يتولى السلطه وهو الذي يسيطر على الموارد
العامه ولهذا السبب في العديد من الجماعات
الدينيه او من مصلحتها ان تدعم الحزب
الحاكم
يكسب الكثيره
على الموارد والذي يحصل فيه اعلى مستويات
البيقراطيه في تركيا
فالقوانين او المنظمات الدينيه
الاقتصادي ولا حتى وصولها نفاذها الى
القوى السياسيه
[موسيقى]